angela is here and so is her hair I
don't want to look at her creepy bouncy
girls in a two-piece well it's JPJ and
Derick round to spit on my face John and
our respectful King leaves us you know I
get that a lot
you're a great guy but
this is your bachelor in paradise
episode 9 recap grab your glasses it's
time for roses and rosy
hi everybody it's me Lauren Zima I sang
the theme song with just an extra little
touch of pizazz just then because look
at this extra touch of pizzazz we have a
new graphic behind me Wow cuz it's like
like you're in paradise like flowers but
also tears you know that's what the show
is actually paradise bachelor
Scarah dice bachelor and dis paradise
right so good to see everybody thank you
guys for being here and for keeping a
smile on my face I have a little rose a
- a little classic moment light and
clear in color that means it's dry you
know it wasn't dry my eyeballs when
Derek left you know I get that a lot
we're gonna get into it mmm okay so
Angela arrives it's paradise you guys
anybody can show up on the beaches be
confident and drink for every not so
okay think Nicole says she calls her
desperate she speaks negatively about
her body
shades I'm CUBAN me she says she's
creepy I don't want to look at her
creepy bouncy girls in a 3-piece clown
and psycho
that was what do you guys think Angela's
here do you think she's here like
rekindle things with play and we're
starting off strong please drink
responsibly but drink every time
someone's like why is she here you guys
think Angela's here
what's he doing hat would you come back
to paradise for Angela's hat
why would you want until they throw your
son into this situation
what's he care no one really knows why
Angela is here you guys why are you all
so shocked she just saw her at the
wedding and Angela makes the point of
saying if clay can be here why can't die
it's okay for him to be here then why is
it not okay for me
and Angela I gray what do you guys think
okay for Angela to be in Paradise let me
know in the comments below as long as
honestly you stay away from clay and
then you can go and do your own thing so
I give Nicole credit for this she just
goes and talks to Angela have the
conversation so many times in life we
find ourselves lost in the confusion
when we don't just have the conversation
I don't I don't want to ruin anything
for you
I really truly
so they talk and Angela seems chill
she's like I don't want drama so do you
agree with Nicole that Angela is a
creepy psychopath I'd only want to look
at her creepy bouncy girls that are
three
I'd say no it was a no for me I'm not
just saying that because I like her hair
angela has it my hairs it might be more
like Angela hair all right have a
conversation later angela has a date
card and she's going to take Mike on the
date I'm confused I needed to see a
conversation between Mike and Sydney
weren't they kind of a thing I guess not
we're not seeing a lot of Mike on
Paradise are we you know I'm here in
Paradise and I think she knows I have
found a connection why bring yourself
and put yourself in the situation so
clay is arguing that Angela knew he had
made a connection in Paradise but did
she because she was on a different story
she's saying that claim never mentioned
Nicole to her when they saw each other
at the wedding and yesterday when we
talked there was no mention of
any girl jacy's behind this camera and
his eyebrows just raised you know it's a
big reveal when JC's like watch no
mention of girl I printed my notes in
the tiniest font today and it was a
horrible idea I'm borderline legally
blind really on behind the scenes
sometimes I can't see the scenes
I need very thick glasses when I order
my glasses they say do you want to get
special lenses so that they're not quite
so thick it's very embarrassing okay oh
my god where is it have you a
conversation with my eyeballs oh right I
wrote down I thought clay was a good guy
I feel like clay he still cares about me
and if it's fine for him to be here then
it's
for me to be here too so I'm not saying
Clay's a bad guy but I did think clay
was more mature than this
we saw him display a lot of grace
during that Christian Jordan fight
moment but it seems that while clay is
good at not fighting with guys he's bad
at not floundering with women I love
this moment we get with tisha tisha lays
it on the line she lays it on the line
she says whoa I'm gonna step up if I
don't do it tisha observes that Nicole
is too left with clay
she says Nicole doesn't see all this
but I do and I'm going to do something
about it because if I don't step up you
will see you tisha tisha confronts clay
and says what are you really doing here
and glaze like I'm ready for
relationship didn't seem that convincing
did he it mean he's a guy with a pretty
monotone voice he doesn't really change
the tone or volume but did you believe
him I would love to take Nicole out of
here in two I don't know
obviously the obvious yeah you were in
love recently
we get a little more Mike we see the
date with Angela and cheers to Mike for
just always being so positive I mean we
are talking about this Angela clay thing
I guess the way I'm looking at in this
room he is here
Angela talks about the double standard
of it being okay for clay to be in
paradise but not her he deserves to be
here and he's ready why would I not you
know what I mean I just feel like I
don't want there to be a double standard
and Mike's like that's beautiful that's
beautiful you say that and then they're
on a boat I don't know why and he can't
really row the boat and he's like we're
going in circles and I love it we're
gonna go in a lot of circles okay
always the listener always positive but
is that the problem I mean they seem to
spend a lot of the day talking about
Angela and clay why aren't we digging
into Mike and Angela is Mike going in
circles just like that boat
I'm just forced to watch my ex date my
friends so I'm not shocked you leave
back to clay and clay is really
victimizing himself isn't he he's saying
I have to watch yours to watch my ex
date my friends in front of me uh clay
you know your ex Angela was gonna have
to watch you date her friends on TV
right on national television in front of
millions how would you want to throw
your side in this situation okay I don't
have the sympathy for clay do you guys I
think clay needs to stop working out and
work out his own issues okay yeah still
think
has some real feelings for play speaking
of issues we're getting high teams with
Blake again and that's nice you know we
had to do our wellness checks on Blake
and now we see that he's okay and I'm
glad also at this point I'm getting a
little lost
on the timeline of paradise you know
what day is it how long have we been
here what's going on tisha is recapping
things and I don't know if this was an
editing flub but she says that John Paul
Jones went on a date with Haley today
also the fact that John Paul Jones went
on a date with Haley today what day is
it
where are we paradise is weird dumpster
fire keeps burning and we love it mm-hmm
Derek's intentions here are not pure
speaking of a dumpster fire John Paul
Jones is still anti Derek he's still on
this road and I gotta say that I might
be taken I left on my road to JPJ like
I'm not feeling so straight ahead
towards the finish line here I feel like
something's off right
did you guys turn a little bit on John
Paul Jones this episode let me know in
the comments below I mean I still love
how funny he is he's talking about how
Derek's a fraud I know the frauds when I
see them okay Derek is a fraud that is a
fact and he says it's a fact that he's a
fraud but I don't have any facts to
prove that fact I don't have like a lot
of like claims to substantiate that
point the listen and that's the fact
that I have no facts
okay Jay PJ I have a pretty good feel
for instinct all right Derek is a creep
man and drink every time John Paul Jones
talked about his intuition
right and he's instinct I feel with
something's off right and it's like John
maybe you should stick with the facts
there's a reason why animals know to fly
south for the winter we have instinct
just like that it's actual facts facts
that are really facts not just not just
feels facts okay plus let's talk about
JPJ saying Derek's a bad guy but many
pointing out that John Paul Jones isn't
exactly a stand-up John Paul gentleman
you know apparently he's like super
imitation
Haley is very hurt by JPJ she says you
told me we had an amazing connection
told me we had an instant connection why
would you give me the rose if you didn't
really feel that way you didn't tell me
you had all these feelings for tisha at
the bar Haley calls out John Paul Jones
and she's not round it off so well why
would you say yes from ID and I want to
just drink for every face Demi is making
behind them the connection raishin
tasted told me that she wanted me to
test the waters I've been a bit play
again
well enough suffers with the right word
we love that dummy and then I had taken
a left on John Paul Jones and now I'm
just making a u-turn and turning right
around I am flipping on John Paul Jones
the way he flips his hair he tells Haley
Haley you're a big girl come on I'm like
you can you're big girl you can explore
your options all right
and much like clay victimizes himself
here as if he's done nothing wrong
John Paul Jones you need to be groans
okay grow up a little bit babe was
locked
welcome to paradise and people are
seeing it right wells is like didn't you
think that went well you think that went
well or do that way not well and
Christian is like did you see your boy
do you see her perspective a little bit
no I totally get it I totally and Haley
is now crying like I don't I mean of all
the people to be crying to about men
they can treat with it like this I don't
she's telling him how men manipulate
women for fun for fun I don't know if I
misheard it you guys told me I think
Blake said to her men well Blake in your
case a lot of people did I did not
fabricate anything but things with JPJ
and Derick are not done they are now
arguing on the beach
and Derick is holding it down you
continue to put words in my mouth I'm
making a good point to John that tisha
decides her life not him she gets to
decide that not you and speaking of
points I think John Paul Jones is
getting lost in his because at a certain
point he just starts laughing don't get
close to me this is us talk John I found
it to be a little unsettling did you
guys who do you think handled this fight
the best I have to be honest I felt
Derek was the better communicator here
this argument on the beach is messier
than John Paul Jones is vomit was just
days ago but someone who's trying to not
be such a mess anymore is Blake I give
Blake credit he's calmed down and he's
getting back to being grounded in
friendship with the ladies drink for
every time you saw Blake just hang in
with the gals this episode
I don't you want some dudes come on yeah
I want is it with you guys was it like
pretty immediate I like it I think it's
a good way to go
Blake be friends with women will learn
how to treat them wonderful so Blake and
the gals are kind of hanging on the
beach having a drink having a little
happy hour and Blake says of this whole
JPJ and Derick thing that has to be
unattractive right this is gonna be the
most unattractive thing ever right and
the girls are like yeah here's how to
attract good called like oh great
Blake with JBJ I'm going left with Blake
are we finally going right I would say
we are but we know he released those
text messages but whatever time it is in
paradise we're still getting new blood
Matt Donald is here
really nervous and I hope I catch your
eye and Luke
[Applause]
ass is here thank God it's not Luke P I
mean in that case P does not stand for
paradise I was scared for a second
someone said Luke there's a girl go but
thank God Luke and they take Sydney and
Christina Schulman on a double date okay
and I just have to pour some more wine
for this moment as they were leaving
Blake said bye Blake are you me am I you
know or not what's happening bachelor in
did you dare dice
and kissing mad yeah that would be nice
on the double date McDonald is Matt not
doing it he won't even kiss Sydney he
says his mom would be ashamed of him my
mom is gonna freaking kill me if I'm
like making out with chicks and stuff
she's gonna kill me Matt I don't know if
you're fit for VIP you might have to be
I see you're way out of here a first
kiss is the absolute minimum of what you
need to be prepared to do here okay yeah
I mean you're entering a season where on
the premiere we learned that somebody
had sex with two different people
back-to-back at a music festival and
you're scared of the first kiss okay
back to the beach and tisha is over it
all she does not want to JPJ sure and
she does not want to Derick she is d4
done so Taoiseach and JPJ are talking
and this conversation looks so difficult
and it's making me sad watching it but
I'm trying to be positive because I do
love her outfit a white shirt on the
beach look is one of my absolute
favorite things just taking them all
over positivity will style moment okay
and yeah that conversation doesn't seem
to go well because do not drink for the
entire time that John Paul Jones is
crying
oh he's a rough crier made my heart skip
a beat for a second there too by the way
just meaningful to me Anant Asia has a
conversation with Derrick and that was
even a little more final she tells
Derrick she doesn't know if she can get
there don't know and oh god Derrick says
do you know that you can't do you know
you can't that was sad that maybe we
want to curl up into myself just pet
myself
it's like Derrick can't someone love
Derek give Derek love he deeper deserves
it but Derrick does a mature thing that
Blake hasn't he leaves you know I'm
actually gonna head out now
he exits paradise and he is crying and
everyone is crying and drink for Katie
because she gave him the hug the
audience wanted to
were you guys shocked Derek left what
did you think should he have gone have
you turned on John Paul Jones we don't
know what time it is but we're very deep
into this season is it still the best
season that paradise we've ever had let
me know in the comments below as always
I love you guys so much thank you for
watching I raise a glass to you I am on
the app cameo if you would like a
personal message from me and now while I
might be turning on JPJ I will never
turn on JC so JC can you just come in
for a moment but Jesse I just want you
to show the people the face of surprise
you make when you're filming and I just
say something that you haven't watched
on the episode yet in your shock never
[Music]
so cute Hey
[Music]